[Music]
on this tuesday night new information
about vaccines
and very rare blood clots canada reports
its first case of a blood clot
after the astrazeneca vaccine as the u.s
suspends the use of the johnson and
johnson shot
this is a really rare event what's being
investigated and what you need to know
will the deal to save air canada fly
there will be
no further job losses what the airline
is agreeing to do
and the impact on taxpayers galen weston
senior the billionaire canadian who
built a retailing empire has died
the mark he left on business and
philanthropy and
tall order rescuing endangered giraffes
from rising flood waters
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
at a time when the vaccine rollout
really needs to ramp up
there is more news tonight about very
rare cases of blood clots involving
two vaccines federal authorities in the
u.s are recommending states
stop using the johnson and johnson
vaccine because six women developed
serious blood clots after getting the
shot and
one of them died to put that into
perspective more than 6.8 million people
in the u.s have already received the
single dose johnson and johnson vaccine
health canada has approved the johnson
johnson vaccine for use here but the
first doses
aren't expected to arrive until the end
of april it says it is watching
developments in the u.s closely
canada pre-ordered 10 million johnson
and johnson doses and has the option to
buy
28 million more today prime minister
justin trudeau tried to reassure
canadians about the vaccine rollout
and even without the johnson and johnson
vaccine
we are going to be receiving over 44
million doses
by the end of june
the other development involves the
astrazeneca vaccine it has been linked
to blood clots in europe and today we
got the first report of a person
developing a blood clot
here in canada we will get to more on
that in just a moment
but we begin with what we know about the
johnson and johnson vaccine pause
in the u.s jackson proskow has our top
story tonight
it was a one in a million reaction that
raised alarm
we are totally aware that this is a very
rare event
we want to get this worked out as
quickly as we possibly can
offering up a dose of caution the fda
and cdc
recommended pausing use of the johnson
and johnson vaccine
while they investigate symptoms appeared
within two weeks of vaccination
all in women aged 18 to 48.
one died one is in critical condition
the fda says it's similar to the rare
reactions reported with the astrazeneca
vaccine
caused by an unusual immune system
response
if it turns out that there's a certain
population that should not be receiving
this or maybe there's a medical sort of
medication
that people should not mix with the
vaccine all that
needs to be figured out now to protect
people
the pause gives time to determine if
there's a problem
it's also a warning to doctors if
recently vaccinated patients develop
symptoms like intense headaches or
abdominal pain
they should avoid certain treatments for
blood clots
that would be a mistake in this
situation because it could be dangerous
and make the situation
much worse as a precaution johnson
johnson says it will now delay rollout
of its vaccine in europe
within hours j j shots were pulled from
vaccination sites across the u.s
in many cases replaced with pfizer or
moderna
in a country where supplies are ample we
have plenty of supply to continue our
vaccination program to hit our goals
the worry is the pause will lead to a
rise in vaccine hesitancy
at a time when covid cases are surging
around the world
the risk of the virus is much worse than
the risk of the vaccine
the vaccine has not been formally pulled
from the u.s market and this pause may
only last a few days
an expert advisory panel will convene on
wednesday to review the blood clot cases
and determine just how significant they
are donna
all right jackson proskow in washington
thank you now
more on that first report in canada
about a blood clot linked to the
astrazeneca vaccine
little detail has been released we know
it is a woman in quebec
who was vaccinated with a dose of
astrazeneca produced by the serum
institute of india it's known as
kova shield the public health agency of
canada says the woman experienced a very
rare
adverse reaction and is now at home
recovering her life is not in danger
five hundred thousand doses of the
astrazeneca cova shield vaccine have
been distributed across canada
another 1.5 million doses are expected
by mid-may
vaccines are the way out of the pandemic
and millions of canadians are anxious to
get them but
these rare cases of blood clots do raise
questions
and ipsos poll for global news found 64
percent of people say the type of
vaccine they are offered will affect
whether they get it
and 82 percent agree they should be able
to choose
which vaccine they receive that
contradicts the official advice that you
take whatever vaccine you are offered
abigail beeman looks at vaccine
hesitancy and what's being done
to combat it it's been really scary it's
been really confusing
blood clot expert dr manica pai knows
her patients and many canadians have
questions about vaccines and blood clots
she says everyone should still take the
first vaccine they're offered
and she tells that to her own patients
people who have a history of blood clots
are likely not at an increased risk of
this
rare event but they certainly are at an
increased risk
of adverse events from a covid19
infection
pai wants people to know the vaccine
safety system is working and doctors are
ready to help
we feel confident that we can diagnose
and treat it so
even though the information is changing
rapidly we are here and we're ready to
protect you
people may be tempted to wait longer to
get vaccinated hoping they don't get
astrazeneca
or when it's available here johnson and
johnson there's a real danger
if you wait for two days in toronto for
example
then you've automatically exposed your
uh
self to a risk of death from covid
that exceeds this very rare risk
of a blood clot whichever vaccine you
are offered is going to be the right one
for you
i think we can definitely be doing a far
better job
scientist and science communicator
krishana sangkar says the desire to shop
around for vaccines
comes from fear instead of you know
making people feel panicked and fearful
we really need to go in with being
empathetic number one
so that we show that yes we do indeed
understand that there are safety
concerns but number two we really
share and look at the data canada's top
doctor acknowledges many canadians have
questions the government is trying to
provide health care workers the tools to
answer them
there is more to be done whether it's
through social media and other channels
to reach the younger age groups vaccine
hesitancy is often on the agenda in
talks between the prime minister and the
provinces
but with a second vaccine flagged for
rare clotting concerns
comes a bigger public relations
challenge abigail beeman global news
ottawa for most people the idea of
air travel is a distant memory and
airlines are bleeding money
over 40 commercial airlines around the
world have gone bankrupt in the pandemic
now the federal government has stepped
in with financial support for air canada
it is four billion dollars in repayable
loans plus
1.4 billion to pay refunds to customers
who had their air canada flights
cancelled because of the pandemic
the government is also buying an equity
stake in the airline
there are conditions about protecting
jobs and resuming some regional routes
the wild card is what happens with air
travel in the months and years ahead
mike armstrong explains
it was news some were desperately
waiting to hear people who forked out
hundreds or even thousands of dollars
for trips on air canada
only to have them canceled samantha kemp
has been fighting to have a flight
reimbursed
for months the fact that it takes the it
took the government to step in and also
took the government
this long is kind of ridiculous to me
there will be no further job losses
the deal gives air canada access to
about 5.9 billion
dollars most of it in low-interest loans
about a quarter of it is supposed to
target reimbursements now giving that
money back to consumers would have been
a challenge for a company that's burning
through reserves has laid off more than
20 000 workers and
canceled about ninety five percent of
flights it's a couple billion dollars
the reimbursements this airline expert
says may not have happened without
ottawa's help
and pressure the optics are very
positive paying the money back and the
government gets
a lot of brownie points because they're
the ones that in effect forced them to
do it but also provided the means to be
able to do it
now there is one part of the deal that
has surprised some observers
ottawa is buying shares in air canada
about six percent equity
one reason to do that may be the
potential return
if airline stocks rebound post pandemic
then the canadian government can rightly
pro about the fact is that they made a
wise investment
and not only did they get the loan money
back but they actually made money on it
under the deal air canada also agrees to
restore regional routes it's suspended
flights to places like comox bc
and sydney nova scotia have to be back
up by june 1st
the deal also limits what air canada
executives can make
the company's last ceo took home more
than 11 million dollars pre-pandemic
that isn't supposed to happen again for
a while executive compensation
is restricted under the terms of this
agreement
there is a cap of one million dollars
total compensation
the big question now is what happens to
the other canadian airlines
westjet and air transit are both in
negotiations
observers expect those deals could come
soon with the air canada arrangement
acting as a template mike armstrong
global news
montreal with me is our senior business
correspondent ann gaviola and
all the airlines are asking for help why
are canada first well it is the most
international in addition to being the
largest airline that we have here in
canada and by that i mean that its
rivals which are based in the us
and europe have already seen targeted
funds targeted relief from their federal
government so this is kind of an attempt
to level that playing field if you will
it's also an opportunity to give air
canada a chance to protect
to keep its spots in international hubs
those spots that it has in airports in
other countries that are important for
connections
and a lot of those airports have
policies where if you're not operating
out of them you lose your spot
and there are plenty of low-cost
regional carriers that are willing to
jump in and get in there
that's going to be important for air
canada to keep its competitive edge as
we get to the other side of this
this is a repayable loan not a bailout
per se what's the likelihood the
billions of taxpayers dollars will be
paid back
and when that's a really good question
now according to the analysts i spoken
with today they tell me that the chances
of air canada
repaying this money is actually quite
good and keep in mind the way that this
deal has been crafted
there are strings attached there are
limits in terms of caps on executive
compensation
there are restrictions on share buybacks
there's even that environmental
reporting piece of it
so these are strings attached that have
been described as pretty onerous
what we've seen in the us is that there
has been
a reluctance from airlines to take
government money that it doesn't need
because they don't want to deal with any
of those conditions
and it really does incentivize them to
repay that money back
more quickly right our senior business
correspondent ann gaviola in toronto
a canadian billionaire and entrepreneur
who built the family business into a
food and retailing empire
has died his family says galen weston
senior died peacefully at his home on
monday after a long illness
the patriarch of the western empire he
took over and turned around
loblaws and went on to acquire multiple
businesses including holt renfrew
and selfridge's group he was also a
philanthropist who donated to a range of
organizations across canada
westin is being remembered as a beloved
husband a proud father and a loving
brother
he was married to former ontario
lieutenant governor hillary weston for
55 years they
raised two children his son galen jr now
ceo of both loblaws and george weston
company
says his father's greatest gift was
inspiring others to achieve
more than they thought possible galen
weston senior was 80 years old
big cuts at a canadian university coming
up dozens of layoffs and programs
lost will it save the school
we think of universities as pillars of
higher learning that once established
just keep going strong but
what's happened at laurentian university
in sudbury ontario has shaken that idea
to the core
yesterday dozens of professors were
fired and multiple
undergrad and graduate programs were cut
eric sorensen explains why
and what a shudder it is sent through
other universities
the deserted campus and the empty
classrooms a consequence of the pandemic
at post-secondary schools everywhere
tells only part of the story at one
university in northern ontario
laurentian hit such dire financial
straits that two months ago it became
the first university in the country
ever to seek creditor protection from
the courts now it is shutting down
programs and laying off professors
like nadia vareli who says she was
blindsided political science was cut
only because political science is one of
the oldest uh
disciplines in the social sciences so
there's a lot of
confusion of anger and a lot of hurt in
all 69 programs including one-third of
undergraduate programs are being closed
from music to environmental studies 34
english language programs are out
as well as 24 french language programs
and eleven
graduate programs for master's degrees
are being discontinued
caitlyn cotella has been a student for
four years it's a
heartbreaking announcement when you're
told that something that you've worked
so hard for
is being ripped away from you at no
fault of your own
laurentian is bilingual with emphasis on
french language and indigenous studies
as well as english
and represents a beacon of higher
education in one of the northern less
populated regions of the country
businesses will close people's
plans for for education in northern
ontario will be disrupted
the ontario government defended its
policies but would say little else as
laurentian goes through creditor
protection
this government remains resolute in
ensuring pathways to graduation for all
students one reason all universities are
hurting is a reliance on foreign
students
who pay much higher tuition costs but
have stayed home during the pandemic
this government has decided to
prioritize using international students
essentially as cash cows to uphold its
entire post-secondary education system
since 2018 we've seen a steady decrease
in public funding for these institutions
and that is what we need to focus on it
is all provincial jurisdiction but the
prime minister says ottawa will weigh
in with ontario to see what can be done
particularly at a bilingual institution
with a focus on minority communities
eric sorensen global news toronto
toronto's interim police chief has
apologized to the city's lgbtq2
community
an independent review found systemic
discrimination was a factor in the
forces handling of several missing
persons cases
the review called for truly
transformative change in the force it
was ordered
after the arrest of bruce mcarthur who
pleaded guilty to murdering eight men
who had gone missing all had connections
to the city's gay village
the report found some officers had
misconceptions or
stereotypical ideas that impeded their
work chief james ramer says toronto
police will act on all 151
recommendations
none of this is acceptable none of this
should have happened
as we all know tragically lives were
lost
to the family friends and community
members left behind
we apologize you deserve better and we
deeply regret the impact
our actions and inactions had and
continue to have
on your lives the chief says toronto
police will double the number of missing
persons investigators he says the
department is exploring how to integrate
civilian support workers into the
missing persons unit
more anger over the shooting of dante
right ahead the resignations
from the police force
you're watching global national
hundreds of protesters defied a dust to
dawn curfew in brooklyn center minnesota
overnight
angry about the police shooting of an
unarmed black man during a traffic stop
the white officer who shot 20-year-old
dante wright and the police chief both
resigned today
the chief of said has said the officer
kim potter mistakenly grabbed her gun
instead of her taser today wright's
mother revealed the last time she saw
her son was
shortly after he was shot when the woman
in the car with him
picked up his phone then she pointed the
phone towards the driver's seat and my
son was laying there
unresponsive that was the last time that
i seen my son
that's the last time i heard from my son
and i have had no explanation since then
next what a new study reveals about
suicide risks during the pandemic
you've never had to think probably about
how you'd rescue a giraffe
well this is how this calf was the last
of nine giraffes stranded on an island
in kenya
rising lake waters repeatedly flooded
their habitat
they're a highly endangered subspecies
called rothschild's giraffes and it took
15 months to plan how to tranquilize
blindfold and ferry them off the island
to a nearby sanctuary that custom-built
barge by the way is called a
g-raft well we're all living through
tough times right now covet-19 has taken
a tremendous toll
drug overdose deaths have increased as
has demand for mental health support
but an international study found no
increase in suicides at least in the
first months of the pandemic
heather urex west explores the possible
reasons why
and what it means for the road ahead
last
june when the world was in the grip of
covin 19's first
wave andrea gordon lost her partner
david to suicide
david felt very isolated he was a very
social person and he
really missed his friends and his family
and the ability to go out and
work full-time all of that was curtailed
for him
all of that was adding to his anxiety
and adding to
his worries about the future gordon
doesn't know if the pandemic was
entirely to blame for her partner's
death but she believes it had an impact
though a new international study
published in the lancet psychiatry
has found that at least in the first
months of covet 19
in many parts of the world suicide rates
did not rise
the research tracked the number of
suicides in 21 countries including
canada
between april 1 and july 31 2020
it found no evidence the pandemic caused
an increased risk of suicide
in fact in 12 areas including bc and
alberta suicide rates actually declined
there was a 24 reduction in suicides in
british columbia
and a 20 reduction in alberta but just
because suicide rates did not increase
in the early days of covet 19 doesn't
mean we're out of the woods yet
for many people stress levels increase
the longer this pandemic drags on
and there will also be long-term mental
health impacts to consider particularly
for health care workers
who will likely deal with post-traumatic
stress long after covert 19
is resolved suicide is often a lagging
indicator
so when something awful happens we don't
typically see suicide go up
we often see a coming together effect
but as time goes on
and people exhaust their personal
resources
life can become more and more bleak i
sat on the advisory committee for that
it's why andrea gordon is now working as
a suicide prevention
advocate sharing her partner's story in
the hope's
other lives can be saved heather urex
west global news
calgary if you or someone you know needs
support there is help including through
crisis services canada
you can call 1-833-456
or text 45645
that is global national for this tuesday
i'm donna friesen
tonight's your canada is the now covid
compliant
lunch break sculpture in downtown
edmonton
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye-bye
you